what's the plan it's like I mean you
know it's if you're not online and I
mean what are what are sort of the I
don't know strategies is the right word
but like if you if you wanted to be very
intentional like I mean look your goal
is to get married and your goal is to to
find a guy and that's what you want but
you haven't been on a date and now
coming up on you know seven months or so
and haven't been in a long-term
relationship in that many years what's
uh what's sort of the plan I mean is it
why why off dating apps in the first
place was it just overwhelming I mean
you know because everybody seems to be
meeting online these days and it seems
like
it's the the taboo has largely gone away
and it's pretty popular I'm surprised
that you're not on them yeah I uh I
stopped using them in about April I just
found I wasn't getting anywhere with
them like nobody wanted to meet in
person and you're wasting your time
talking to people um or you just didn't
meet the right people like and some a
lot of weirdos it is easier to filter
them but lots of weirdos like I I kid
you not one guy told me that he shares
women with his dad and he sent me dick
pictures of his dick and his dad's dick
so like I can't make this stuff up so
just
yeah this is how low and weird the B is
dudes like those of you watching there's
a lot of weird awkward people out are
you guys hearing this right now yeah no
I've heard stories like this over and
over again no I've heard stories like
this over and over again MF it's like
there's a lot of weird uncalibrated
dudes that don't like there's a time and
a place for stuff like that and it's
usually when you get to the right like
I'm not going to have to explain it here
it's YouTube it's a little more you know
pg-rated sort of stuff so but um there's
there's a time and place for everything
and most dudes aren't that calibrated um
there's also a like a contingent of men
that that just aren't looking for
long-term relationship and they just
want to hook up like a lot of dating
apps really are you know a lot of guys
are just like hey you know let's try to
get to the bang sort of thing right well
that's another thing they pretend
they're interested in a relationship but
they just want to hook up with
you do you make them wait a certain
period of time
or uh usually yeah certain done I have
done hookups in the past like
unintentionally but it's just uh it's a
waste of 20 seconds of my life
okay but as far Brianna's got something
to say about that it sounds like but I
mean like as far as as far as dating
though like if you want to be taken
seriously and you want to get wiped up
is there a certain period of time that
you have in your head like a certain
number of dates that you'd want to make
the guy wait to see if he was serious
about you or how do you usually approach
that um definitely over a month I guess
it depends like how often you see them
because if if it's been one month of
talking but you only went on one date
then obviously longer than that so it
depends like at least a
[Music]
month um Brianna you had a giggle at
that 20 second comment can you Enlighten
us I just think that's something that a
lot of women can relate to you know it's
like the guy
will finish in 25 seconds or whatever
and then be like that was great did she
finish too
do you find that do you think men are
generally bad in bed on on average I
mean I hear this a lot from women where
it's like a lot of men are painfully
terrible in the bedroom yes yes
yes what advice would you have for men
when it comes to that
intimacy or what makes them bad what
makes them bad at it and then you know
things you're just like try to keep
it the YouTu this isn't only fans but
it's you know let's uh yeah you know as
descriptive as you can be with you know
give
PG-13 know your anatomy and how to put
it in the
hole maybe a little more eloquent than
that I don't maybe a little more more
but like so I'm serious is it something
you just know I mean so like what are
some of the things it's like oh like
this guy doesn't know what he's doing
like I mean what are some of the Dead
giveaways I this is important to women
right to be pleasured in the bedroom
clearly I mean there's no question about
that like MF and I understand that but
there's a lot of guys that are just like
one pump Chumps I guess and they don't
understand the um the bedroom game
component of things uh which will women
won't give you the next date if you if
you can't perform right I mean the bar
is low like I've said before to you guys
the bar is low for a lot of dudes right
like it's like you know don't whip out a
tuna sandwich don't send you know
dickpics before you actually have
intimacy lasts more than one pump sort
of thing um know how to put it in the
hole sure um what advice would you have
for guys on that P and Bri on you know
the notion of intimacy so that they
would would be better and sort of fit
the mold that you expect them
to
I I don't know that's a good question I
don't
um
um I guess look for like the physical
cues or hopefully you're with a woman
that is like comfortable and confident
enough to say like oh I actually like
this or this is what I would prefer you
do um just pay attention I feel like a
woman's body I mean women usually don't
want to tell guys what to do they want
guys to just sort of get it in the
bedroom right just get it like is there
anything less attractive to you ladies
about telling them man like what to do
in the bedroom like explaining how sex
Works
um I don't I don't know I don't really
have a lot of experience maybe maybe
I'll phrase it to you this way like
given the preference would you rather
explain to him how intimacy works or
would you rather him just get it and
perform well I mean I think everyone
would rather him just know what to do
and how to do it and do it well P what's
your take on that uh yeah but
communication is important non-verbal
and verbal like I get it some people
like expect you to read their mind but I
think I've just reached the point where
I don't have a filter so I'll just just
communicate because it's just it's just
way easier nobody can read your mind
they don't know what you want just just
tell them but if you had the choice if
you had the choice between a guy where
you have to really explain it and sort
of walk him through it step by step
versus a guy where you can because we
had Brianna on last week and we we talk
a lot about about uh men being the ones
that lead romantic interactions and Lead
relationships and Lead dates and you
know in this case lead in the in the
bedroom and in the intimate side so my
guess is that you'd prefer a guy that
just gets it and that can take the lead
without being told what to do over a guy
that you're walking through if you had
the choice between the two is that
right uh they the same personality same
compatibility let's say all everything
across the board is the same the one
thing is like this guy has no idea what
he's doing I mean but maybe maybe we
even say like let's say a guy like would
you be with a guy or would you consider
a guy dating longterm if he was a virgin
per se you know is that a burden that
you'd be willing to take on I don't know
if burden's the right word or is that
something that you're like no because a
lot of women say they prefer a guy with
at least some experience but what are
you what's your take on it like a virgin
guy uh it's not a deal breaker for me
but then like what's his dating
experience like because I don't want to
be the first person he's dated like he
should he should get some dating you
know just like you should have life
experience uh in travel experience you
should get some dating experience too I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the fulllength
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out